Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs.com which is the largest online
marketplace for graphic design with more than 850,000 registered designers from
all over the world who compete for your business.
I've used them for years and I've used them for some very big projects like the
book cover for the four hour body,
which went on to becoming number one New York Times Bestseller,
translated into at least I would say 10 1520 languages and I used 99 designs
because I needed results and I needed them very quickly.
So here's how it works.
You need a logo,
a website,
book cover,
tee shirt,
car APP,
whatever.
You put a description on 99 designs.com then people submit designs and in a week
or less you have an original design that you love or you get 100% of your money
back.
So check out 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
you can see some of the projects that I've done personally and you can also get
a $99 upgrade for free.
This highlights your project,
listing it with a prominent background,
bumping it to the top of the page.
And on average this will attract close to 200% more designs.
So check out 99 designs.com forward slash Tim and I think you'll like what you
see.
This episode has two amazing guests,
Tony Robbins and Peter Diamandis,
and we're going to talk principally about how to think big,
what is involved in thinking big,
really 10 x 20 x saying what you're trying to do and siphoning down the bio's of
these two gents was very,
very challenging.
Uh,
both of them make me look like a real lazy bastard who hasn't done anything with
his life,
which is inspiring to me.
So there are different ways to take it,
but let's get started.
Tony Robbins,
for those of you who don't know,
he's often called a motivational speaker and I think that's a total misnomer
because he is really a peak performance strategist and his clientele is really
astonishing.
He has consulted or advised people,
including Nelson Mandela,
Mikhail Gorbachev,
Margaret Thatcher,
Princess Di Mother Teresa.
He's consulted members of two royal families,
members of us,
Congress,
the US army,
US marines,
three US presidents including Bill Clinton and some of his other celebrity
clients include Serena Williams,
Andre Agassi,
golf legend,
Greg Norman,
Leonardo Dicaprio.
The list goes on and on and on.
Uh,
he's been named by Accenture,
one of the top 50 business intellectuals in the world by Harvard business press
is one of the top 100 business gurus by American Express,
one of the top six business leaders in the world.
And,
and I should say certainly last but not least,
he is the creator of a product that many of you may have seen around,
which is the number one personal and professional development system of all time
called personal power.
I have quite a background with this program and in a future episode,
Tony,
and I'll be talking a lot about it,
but personal power has sold more than 40 million audiotapes and CD copies
worldwide.
Uh,
he himself has also developed and produced five award winning television
infomercials.
And here's the stat that might blow your mind.
They have been continuously aired on average every 30 minutes,
24 hours a day,
somewhere in North America since April,
1989.
Okay.
So for more than 20 years,
I guess,
25 years,
every 30 minutes,
24 hours a day.
A Tony Robbins infomercial has been on television in North America.
It's amazing and that is just a small fraction of his bio.
But I don't want to cut Peter Short.
Peter Diamandis or I should say doctor Peter Diamandis has been named one of the
top the world's 50 greatest leaders by Fortune magazine in the world of
innovation.
Uh,
Diamandis is chairman and CEO of the x Prize Foundation,
best known for its $10 million Ansari x prize for private space flight.
The x prize is really intended to lead the world in designing and operating
large scale global competitions to solve what,
uh,
Peter might call market failures.
He's also the co founder and Vice Chairman of Human Longevity Inc uh,
genomics and cell therapy based diagnostic and therapeutic company focused on
extending the healthy human lifespan.
Uh,
it goes on.
He is the Co founder and EXEC chairman of Singularity University.
I've actually spent time there as adjunct faculty basically in the
entrepreneurship track.
This is based at Nasa Ames Center.
It's a graduate level Silicon Valley institution studies exponentially growing
technologies,
their ability to transform industries and solve humanity's grand challenges.
Ray Kurzweil,
some of you may know also very involved with that and in the field of commercial
space,
Diamandis is the co founder and Co Chairman of Planetary Planetary.
I need more caffeine,
planetary resources,
a company designing spacecraft.
Check this out to enable the detection and mining of asteroids for precious
materials.
These two guys are amazing.
I think you'll really enjoy this conversation.
And often what holds us back is not lack of resources.
It's not lack of tools necessarily,
it's lack of ambition.
We don't have dreams,
aspirations that are big enough to really catapult us to the next level of
thinking,
strategy,
operation,
and so on.
Execution for that matter.
So I wanted to bring these two guys on and talk about how on earth they got to
be where they today in terms of just magnitude of impact and,
and,
and sheer sort of force of will.
So I hope you enjoy it.
Without further ado,
please meet Tony and Peter.
Little Ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
I'm very excited to have two of my friends on the line,
Peter Diamandis and Tony Robbins.
Gentlemen,
how are you?
Great.
Are you,
I'm very well I know that you're both very busy and uh,
I will want to dive into quite a few different subjects.
So right off the Bat I think that uh,
the,
the topic,
the general topics and I think there are two intertwined that I'd love to
explore in this conversation are number one,
I think,
uh,
an aspect of your psychology is the both of you very well known for.
And that is thinking big.
So I'm going to dive into that.
But how you started thinking big and really big in many cases.
And then secondly,
how you learn and how you have learned.
And so I thought a very perhaps tactical way to start off and just jump into it
would be asking you each and maybe,
uh,
Peter,
we could start with you.
Uh,
what book or books you've gifted to other people the most outside of your own?
sure.
Uh,
there's actually a few books that have changed my world that I've gifted a,
the first is reading the spirit of Saint Louis,
buy Lindbergh.
And you know,
the setting is his story of this epic adventure in 1927 of crossing the Atlantic
and doing it for $25,000 prize.
And I was amazed at this man,
his determination and the way he thought about this and took the risk out and
then made this epic journey.
So that's one.
I love atlas shrugged by ign rand.
It's uh,
something I've read multiple times to sort of get me in the mindset of not
letting anything stand in my way and really driven by passion,
which I know is nothing.
Something that Tony knows nothing about it.
Yeah,
no,
definitely kits.
Sorry to interrupt.
Please continue.
No,
no.
There are two others that have been sort of man who sold the moon,
which is a science fiction book by Robert Heinlein.
It talks about how this guy dd Herrmann commercializes the moon and it's just a
brilliant 50 year old vision that's as relevant today.
And then,
uh,
a book by my good friend Ray Kurzwell called the singularity is near,
which was the,
the basis for the foundation of singularity university.
And it's funny cause all of these books,
each of them and in turn,
uh,
we're so purposeful to me.
They,
they were the drivers for me starting many of my companies.
Awesome.
That's it.
That's a,
I'm going to go pick up all of this.
This is a side note for folks Heinlein,
uh,
for those of you who use the word Grok,
Grok this grok that that is from stranger in a strange land.
Also by Heinlein.
A lot of techies don't realize the origins of that word.
Uh,
Tony,
I'd love to love to hear your,
your selection.
I was,
it tends what people really want over the years.
Probably the most common books I've recommended to us as a man thinketh by James
Allen because,
uh,
when you think about the quality of people's lives,
it starts with the what?
Meaning we give things to people could have the same exact experience and one
person thinks it's over and one person thinks the game has begun.
And that is the difference that makes the difference in the quality of people's
lives.
It's not what happens to them as we all know.
Uh,
and the other one,
which is along the same theme that I've probably given out as well,
I give that as them,
I think it's good to a small book.
It's a book that people can read over and over again and get great value out of
it.
But man,
search for meaning by Viktor Frankl to me is just one of the greatest books ever
written.
Um,
because we all in our lives.
The one thing that's in common for all human beings,
regardless of your background or your economic position,
good,
bad,
or indifferent.
We're all gonna experience extreme stress in our life.
At some point,
everyone's going to have to face the loss of a loved one.
Everyone's got the face of the loss of a job or an opportunity or a government
change in policy that affects your business or some health issue yourself,
uh,
or robbery or the loss of your home burglary burning down.
I mean,
all these horrible things in your lifetime,
you're going to experience and to be able to learn from someone who experienced
the Holocaust directly who normally experienced the holocaust,
but walked through.
What was the difference between those who made it and those who didn't?
And as most of us who've read the book,
No,
it wasn't the strongest that survives.
It was those that had a higher meaning for their pain.
Those that found a way to even take suffering and transform it into a meaningful
experience.
Know,
most people today,
we live in a society where people think happiness is what life's about.
But you can get bored being happy.
Some people,
you know,
they're so damn happy,
they create a problem just to have variety in their life because we have lots of
needs as human beings and they make a problems.
They don't even have.
I did well,
extremely wealthy clients and you should,
you know,
some people hear their problem to go,
yeah,
I'd love to have those problems.
So meaning is what really matters and to,
to witness to go through the experience and an associated way and see how this
man not only transformed his own life but then came back to help.
So many others I think is one of the more invaluable components.
But another book would be the fourth turning because I also believe you have to
understand that life has seasons.
And the fourth turning is written by two brilliant men who actually to an
original book that,
and Clinton gave me when I worked with them 20 years ago called generations,
which goes through,
you know,
a hundred years of jabs,
generations and walks through how basically we adapt to the way we've been
brought up and bring up our children differently and how that crepes gross
patterns that affect history.
How about the fourth turning is just an incredibly in depth experience that
shows you that human beings go for periods of time,
10,
15,
20 years,
usually from 10 to 15 year range of the stage.
We are now where we have a primary set of emotions.
There are winters where people will tend to find what's wrong.
There's the springtime of possibility,
there's the hot summer,
and of course there's the fall where the rewards are very,
very simple and you can tie these economics,
you can tie them to emotions.
Um,
and it's just an extraordinary book to put your life in perspective.
And so you learn,
you know,
some people freak out in the winter,
other people,
you know,
some people freeze that out,
some people ski and snowboard part and how to take advantage of whatever season
of life you're in and how to utilize that 10 anticipate in your business and
your life.
I find that the unvaluable but it depends on what somebody's looking for.
I just recommended slow sex to somebody yesterday who desperately needed it and
you're cold,
you know,
and,
and another person,
I was watching them deal with their kid and I said,
you've got to go pick up mindset by the Stanford University cause you're keep
telling your kid how perfect they are and you're going to ruin them because
telling a kid that they're perfect crates,
a frame of reference where they have to be a certain way as opposed to giving
them the feedback because they put out the effort,
effort they can control who you are is a whole different component.
So I'm always honestly seeing what's needed for that individual now.
But if I'm going universal,
I think it's understanding the seasons of life.
It's understanding,
creating meaning and it's understanding how your thoughts have the ultimate
control of your life.
No,
I agree.
And uh,
the,
I think for,
for those people,
curious to dig into also the,
the parenting aspect event you mentioned,
I think that brain a brain rules,
uh,
and the author,
I think his name is a professor Medina out of Washington also underscores that
as does Josh Waitzkin actually who I interviewed on this podcast,
who was the basis for searching for Bobby Fischer.
And you talked about the same thing.
How emphasizing sort of effort over attributes is,
is and continues to be increasingly important in raising children.
The,
the,
the s was sort of macro level aspect of both of you that that jumps out most
immediately to a lot of people.
It's just the sheer scale of what you do.
And uh,
so Tony for instance,
I mean,
how many,
how many people are you going to be feeding a or are you aiming to feed?
And in 2015,
three years,
it started out with,
when I was 11,
somebody fed my family.
I don't even know it was.
I just met the man at the door who delivered the food and it radically changed
my life,
cause it,
the meaning I took out of it was at strangers care.
If strangers cared about my family,
then regardless of my father told me I was going to care at a different level.
It changed my entire life.
So I said,
you know,
when this happened,
I was 11 when I'm 17 was the first time I fed two families and then for the next
year,
then the eight,
and then it was getting a little tough.
So I got some friends involved and then my companies grew.
So now from the last 37 years,
I've fed 42 million people,
but I'd feed about 4 million,
2 million people each year through my foundation.
And I do 2 million myself.
I do matching funds for the last five years.
So,
but this year or last year,
I don't know if you saw,
but a lot of people didn't even notice a congress cut food stamps by eight point
$2 billion,
which is the equivalency you understand of the family's there.
Supporting going without food one week out of the month,
just arbitrarily without figuring out how to make up for it.
And I obviously work pretty passionately with all these nonprofits cause I help
support them all and they're being maxed out.
And so I thought,
you know what,
I'm writing this book right now and Finances and I'm fortunate to do quite well.
What if I took all the money of that and I donated it,
you know,
how many meals can I donate?
And that wasn't enough.
So I said,
well,
I'll write a check above that.
And I thought if I could do as many meals that I've none in my lifetime in a
year,
that'd be a good start.
So I said,
you know,
okay,
I've got to find 42 million meals.
Holy Shit,
that's a large drink of water.
How bout how bout I do need everything in the book.
And I put up a big check and I feed 20 million people this year and I get
matching donations.
But as I've gone along,
I've gotten more inspired and I've partnered with fat,
um,
feeding America,
which is the largest domestic feeding organization,
that best organization,
and I've negotiated with them to cut out all of the costs and I'm now,
I've raised my game,
I'm like Todd total number and I'm writing a check for and a few weeks,
November 18th is 55 million meals.
I'm personally going to deliver 55 million people and then they're going to
partner with me to get that to 100 million with matching funds.
So I know for sure I'm going to feed 55 million this year.
That's not counting my foundation or the other work that I do.
So I guess it will be slightly.
And these numbers to most people are just almost unimaginable.
And so that just does.
Peter,
just due to perhaps catch people up on a couple of examples of the work you've
done with the x prize,
of course you'd done many different things in addition to the x prize.
Uh,
but what are,
what are some of the problems that you're attempting or are tackling or have
tackled with,
with the x prize to date?
And I know we're going to,
certainly,
we all have sort of a secret agenda to talk about one that we're particularly
passionate about right now,
but what are some of the others that you can mention?
Sure.
So,
um,
people might know the work we do here for the original Ansari x prize per space
flight modeled after Lindbergh's flight across the Atlantic to win a $25,000
prize.
We put up $10 million back in 1996 for the first unit,
build a spaceship and carry three adults up into space and back.
And the relevance here is that individuals today can do extraordinary things and
you need to give them guidance.
You know,
without a target,
you'll miss it every time.
And if you incentivize them,
you can get entrepreneurs from any place,
any walk of life independent,
what they've done before to do extraordinary things when I fundamentally believe
that.
So the question is,
can you point entrepreneurs at the world's biggest problems?
The grand challenges and that's where we're doing.
And um,
and oceans and health and learning and energy.
One of the prizes I think that's relevant that we're in the midst of right now
is called the Qualcomm tricorder x prize.
So anybody who's a fellow Trekkie,
I knows a star trek,
know Dr. McCoy bones would have this device called the tri quarter.
He'd pointed it at somebody and be able to tell if they're bright Gillian fever
or if they're an alien or whatever the case might be.
And is sort of the,
the vision of where we're going.
So we partnered with Qualcomm,
Paul Jacobs,
who the chairman there,
or they put up $20 million,
uh,
and we have teams around the world to build a handheld mobile device,
a nonproductive for nurse.
It's for a mom or dad at two in the morning when their kid is sick.
And this is a device you can talk to.
It's got AI,
artificial intelligence on the cloud.
You can cough on it.
It can do the RNA and DNA analysis of the bacteria in your,
in your sputum.
You do a blood prick and do your blood chemistries,
it's meant to be able to diagnose you independent of the medical system,
which is so broken right now.
And you know,
the,
we had 300 teams entered the competition.
We're down to the top 10.
We'll have a winner in 15 months.
But you know,
people are starting to put doctors and nurses out of business.
And the answer is no,
we've got a problem right now.
There's going to be,
we're going to be short,
um,
uh,
something on the order of 100,000 doctors in the u s alone by 2020.
And that's great compared to the rest of the world.
Africa has got 25% of the disease burden and 1.3% of the healthcare workers.
We could not scale building hospitals or were physicians fast enough.
So can we use technology to touch the lives of a billion people?
And um,
so that's,
that's one of them.
The Qualcomm tricorder xprize and way I think about it is imagine technology
that a mass cy warrior in the middle of Kenya today has access to a smartphone
with Google.
They have access to more knowledge and information.
And President Clinton had 20 years ago,
uh,
and they're paying a dollar a day,
this democratization.
Uh,
and this demonetization is where we're heading.
And I think what I'd love to ask both of you and,
uh,
Peter perhaps we could start with you,
is when did you sort of leave this very incremental,
linear sinking?
Because for a lot of people,
they hear millions of dollars,
tens of millions of dollars,
and they,
they immediately respond in their own head with,
I could never do that.
I could never raise that type of money,
make that type of money,
have that type of impact.
And when I interviewed Peter Teal on the podcast,
some people may have heard it,
but he's obviously known as a billionaire investor,
first money into Facebook,
cofounder of Palentier.
But back in the day,
he was on a very traditional track to becoming a lawyer.
And he ended up not getting a clerk,
a clerkship,
a clerking position.
Uh,
and that was sort of the,
the redirection that sent him into what would later become paypal.
And now of course he poses questions like,
why don't you take your 10 year plan and ask yourself,
why can't I do this in six months?
And it just,
it turns out that sometimes you can actually formulate a plan that works based
on asking better questions,
but you,
for,
for him,
there were a few moments that really shook him or showed him that the
incremental approach was not the only approach.
So,
so Peter,
I'm curious,
at what point did you develop this thinking or who impacted you?
What were the triggers that sort of led you to think this big?
Great,
great question.
And uh,
um,
you know,
it was probably,
so I grew up passionate about space,
you know,
watching the tail end of Apollo,
drinking all the Tang and got my hands on watching star trek.
And it was driven by this inner purpose and mission and passion.
And I sort of attached that to becoming an astronaut and joining NASA.
And that was my vision of my future.
And as I got closer and closer to meeting astronauts and meeting and seeing what
was really going on behind NASA,
I realized that it was never going to happen to the government.
And honestly,
uh,
NASA had become so risk adverse of that.
It was massively disappointing and there was this disconnect between my vision
of where the world should be and the way it was and the way it was going.
And I had this moment in time where I literally,
when I was at Grad school at Mit,
I did not submit my astral an application and I said,
screw it,
forget I'm going to take,
I'm going to do this myself.
And I made a commitment to myself to work,
to open up the private space frontier on my own,
which is an insane concept to think about.
Well,
when did you,
were you sitting having a cup of coffee and just like looking across the cafe,
did some,
I mean,
what,
what was,
what was the moment when you were like,
screw it?
I was in,
I was in the man vehicle lab at Mit.
I was doing research on human physiology and I had a bunch of shuttle astronauts
in the lab and I was talking to them,
it would Byron Lichtenberg and Oh and Garrett and a number of folks.
And I was listening to their stories of how,
what they had to do to get into NASA and how they had to be a good boy and do
what they were told,
which is not me by any stretch of imagination.
No.
And,
and,
and then I was told,
you know,
your chance of being like a one of a thousand,
if you get selected,
maybe you'll fly in if you fly,
you might fly once or twice in your career.
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
that's ridiculous.
I mean it's a not this,
this is bullshit.
This is not my vision of way opening up spaces is going to be.
And it was so antithetical and I had so much energy and emotion tied to this
desire that I literally poured that all into a brand new approach.
Um,
which became zero gravity corporation,
x prize space,
adventures,
planetary resources,
a whole bunch of things.
And we're just beginning.
And,
and I,
I,
I think it is now possible for an entrepreneur to do anything to take on any
grand challenge.
And,
and I think it's,
it's an important message.
You can stop complaining about problems and start solving them.
That's what we're living in today.
And is there just to look at,
say the Ansari x prize.
So it's $10 million,
uh,
going from MIT to say the first x prize.
Obviously there,
there were a lot of different steps in between,
but someone,
I just,
I know this may seem like I'm beating a dead horse on this site,
$10 million,
but it's such an unfathomable number for a lot of people.
So I didn't have $10 million right now.
Hope you're going to stare at this.
Walked out with 10 million.
Come on.
Peter told the story.
He told me this story is like,
all right,
you're my brother.
All right,
cool.
Yeah,
no,
let's,
let's go.
The fact of the matter is,
I read the book,
the spirit of Saint Louis and my good friend Greg Man,
it gives me an,
I hear about it and I go,
hey,
if I can create a prize,
maybe that's them.
That's the means.
I get my ass into space.
Right?
And so I start noodling this as I'm reading the book,
10 million bucks is enough money,
you know,
I'm going to call the x prize because I had no idea who's going to put up a 10
million bucks.
He x was going to represent the name of the person who would eventually put up
the money I had to variable to be replaced.
So long story short on like scrambling for back then,
you know,
100 bucks here,
1000 bucks,
they're getting the seed money to get this going.
And I ended up in Saint Louis where an amazing man,
Al Kurth said,
I will help you re raise some seed money.
And then he was driven and connected by my passion,
my commitment to this.
And he helped me raise about a half a million dollars in 10 and 20 k checks from
the people and people connect with your passion,
with your heartfelt desire to do something bigger than yourself and they're
willing to back that to some extent.
Long story short,
over the course of a year and a lot of,
you know,
worn out knee pads,
I raised end up raising half a million dollars and then our fundraising stalls
and we make the very bold decision that we're going to announce this $10 million
prize anyway,
but with no money in place.
And uh,
we ended up,
uh,
going out under the arch in St Louis.
And one of the things I teach entrepreneurs,
in fact,
I write about this in my next book called bold,
which is how you announced a big bold idea to the world really matters if you
announce it below a line of credibility.
We all have a line of credibility around ideas.
We judged them constantly.
If you announce the below the line of credibility,
people dismiss it out of hand.
And then we had this line of super credibility that if you announce it above the
line of super credibility,
people say,
wow,
when is it going to happen?
How can I be involved?
So for me,
even though I didn't have $10 million,
I didn't have any teams.
Uh,
I got on stage to stand by my side,
you know,
20 astronauts from Buzz Aldrin and others,
uh,
the head of NASA,
the head of the Faa,
who had seen me over many years.
And it took a lot of convincing.
I mean,
this is where the even getting to that point was a pinnacle of years of work,
but driven by this commitment.
So we announced this prize front page around the world and because I'm
absolutely,
positively sure I'm going to raise the $10 million,
who wouldn't want to pay 10 million after a pro after a person did it,
right?
You paid only on success challenges 150 CEOs later over the next five years,
between 96 and 2001,
everyone's turning me down.
Um,
I finally meet the Ansari family.
There's a lot more detail here,
but listen,
the fact of matter is if I,
there were many times at 3:00 AM in the
when,
uh,
okay.
I was tempted to give up and it was only because I was being driven by my
internally,
my,
you know,
my own massively transformative purpose that kept me going in.
And we're here today having this conversation because I did not give up.
So I'll leave it up.
Dot.
No,
I love that story.
And I think what's,
what's,
what I'd love to underscore it as much for myself as anyone else is that you
also had the public accountability because you'd made that I burn my ships,
dude.
Yeah.
You,
you burn your ships.
So,
uh,
that's a wonderful story.
It's Tony.
I know a lot about your story and of course we're going to have a followup
conversation to talk about many other things.
Uh,
but I've read all your books,
listen to a lot of your material,
and I know that you weren't always the Tony Robbins said,
people know of today.
I mean,
there was a point where you were sort of,
uh,
well there's a lots of the story of course,
but what were,
what were the triggers for you?
The influences,
the moments where you sort of decided,
okay,
instead of helping an additional,
you know,
feeding an additional two people per year or making an additional 10 k per year
or whatever it might be in those sort of increments where you went to really
getting bold as,
uh,
as Peter might say.
I think it's driven.
I think it unfolds with time.
There are moments along the way,
but there are inevitable moments that come with growth.
And growth only comes if there's something,
as Peter said,
that you're passionate about,
that's larger than yourself.
Cause it's very easy to become satisfied with a certain amount of money,
a certain amount of food at certain amount of sex,
a certain amount of comfort,
a certain amount of anything.
But if you said to me,
what is the difference in people's lives and what's the difference between
heater as I love dearly and the average person,
it's hunger.
It,
he's an incredibly intelligent man.
You know,
he understates who he is and it's just pure level of intelligence.
But you truthfully,
I've seen people that have one Tempe intelligence accomplish more because that
hunger is my hunger from the earliest day was the light p up people up.
And I think it's because I was surrounded by so much suffering.
I mean I hate to see people suffer.
I love to light people up.
And I found early that would like people up was answers,
answers that could change the quality of life immediately where they get
suddenly shift their body and their energy would change,
their body would change.
They could lose 20 or 30 pounds,
that they could change the relationship and suddenly something was dead,
was fully alive and there was passion.
Cause I don't care who you are and where they can make $10 billion.
And I know,
cause I get the calls from these people that it's not the game.
The game is your body.
It's your emotions that your relationships,
if everything else in your life was going great,
and there's an area that isn't in inevitably will bite you because we're
designed as human beings to grow or die.
That's just how it works spiritually,
mentally,
emotionally.
So along the way,
I wanted answers for myself to start with.
I was short,
I was fat,
we were,
I grew up in a very tough environment.
I had four different fathers,
we had no food,
no money.
Those things kind of trigger you.
And,
and as a result,
I didn't,
couldn't answers in my environment.
I didn't have access to anybody.
So for me it was book.
So I'm very passionate about the power of what,
how self learning can transform anybody,
especially in the world we have today where you have access to everything,
literally at your fingertips,
on your phone,
anywhere you go.
But I had 700 books in a period.
I thought I was gonna be a book a day.
That was my goal.
I took a speed reading class,
but I didn't do that.
I read 700 bucks over seven years,
but I read anything I could on physiology,
psychology,
emotion,
anything I can make the difference in the quality of people's lives.
And then gradually what happened was I started,
you know,
going from books to being able to use net time,
no extra time,
I want to listen to things.
I started listening those days to cassette tapes.
That's how old I am.
And as I went through the process,
I then found myself at events and I went to an event that changed my life was
the first real teacher was this man named Jim Roan,
who is a personal development teacher,
was a three hour event.
I sat in this room and I watched this man who's just so lel in three hours share
with people principles that I knew would change the quality of my life are
there.
It's,
and I decided to go to work for him because I thought,
this is what I want my life to be about,
this guys the best at what he does.
I want to live this stuff.
And so I went to work for him.
And the core essence that I got from being around him was the quality of your
life is really comes down to your capacity to add value that in life,
the only thing that makes you feel fully alive as growing and giving.
And that evolves my language of it.
I,
that's what I pulled by being around him.
Not so much by what he said,
but when he said that grabbed me in those early days that started opening my
world was,
you know,
my mother wanted me to become a truck driver.
There was this truck,
masters driving school,
these to advertise on television and she was obsessed that I could make $24,000
a year,
which was twice as much as my father.
If I just go to truck driving school and then I'd have this open road and I
bought,
you know,
Adam could drive that truck far enough,
fast enough,
long enough to change the world.
That's not going to change the world.
That's not what my passion is.
And so I went to this event and I saw this man,
I walked out of there and I said it's about adding value.
He showed me that at all levels,
including economics,
that if you found a way to do more for others than anybody else,
you would have the opportunity to grow,
expand heavy impact,
be economically free,
have the choices you want.
The next big chunk was when I got exposed because I was always looking for new
teachers to a man named John [inaudible] who taught neurolinguistic programming
or NLP.
And I watched this man take people in minutes and create changes they've been
working on in decades.
And so I became obsessed.
There was nobody in that community other than therapist and those early days.
And I convinced him that,
you know,
1819 I guess you are told the time to let me come sit in his class cause I was
going to put my ear to the door anyway,
no matter what.
And I w I took notes like crazy at the end of the class.
And then there was a day there where this person,
he was out of the room and this person started going through this,
this phobic exposure and started freaking out and screaming.
And I'm in a room with 70 people and they're all therapists and nobody's doing
anything.
And so I just stood up and I just grabbed this person and I just,
I,
I wasn't gonna let him stop her.
And then everything that I'd learned consciously and unconsciously came out and
was like magic.
And you know,
15 minutes later it was gone and John Walked in the room,
everyone's like,
you just see what this guy did.
You know,
he's a phenol,
I know clean.
I'm,
all I did was,
I cared so much,
I had so much intensity for the issue and it's like I,
you know,
I don't know how to give,
I didn't know how to give somebody a mouth to mouth resuscitation.
I was in a place of my father in law where he dropped and I mean dropped.
And nothing that I had learned made a difference.
And somewhere in my head and milliseconds while he was dying and turning gray,
my brain remembered having seen some hundred goop to talk about.
It's not mouth to mouth,
it's press compressions to get blood into the brain.
Where does your brain come up with that?
It comes up because it's attuned to answers.
When you become an an altered state of state of passion,
a state of commitment,
a state of Musk.
When,
when you listened to Peter,
when you put himself on the line,
when he,
you know,
the way you take,
as you said,
you take the island,
you burn the boats in those moments,
the answer's there.
So then I started making that my modus operandi.
I want on,
you know,
national radio in Canada.
And I challenged psychologists and psychiatrists after I had four days of
training.
And I said,
I don't care what your problem is.
I don't care if you,
uh,
if you have uncontrollable phobias,
see me,
I'll handle it literally in one hour or less.
And you know,
then I got challenged.
Psychiatry is called me on the phone and made my whole career by saying,
you're a liar.
You're a charlatan.
People like you should not be allowed on the radio.
And I said,
sir,
I said,
have you ever met me?
Said of course not.
I see if you ever met my clients.
He said,
of course not.
I said,
so are you a scientist?
He's well,
I'm a physician.
I said,
are you a scientist?
good,
cause the scientist would never make an assumption.
What you're telling me is what you're proposing is your hypothesis.
The stripe hypothesis is that I'm a charlatan wire,
so let's prove it.
I'm at the Holiday Inn tomorrow night.
Anyone listening,
come bring me your worst patient.
Bring me somebody you've never been able to cure.
I said,
I'm sure you've got plenty of those and I and typhus,
dido point.
We had nowhere to go,
and so he brought me this woman,
he treated for seven years a snake phobia,
which she dream about a snake in the middle of the night,
wake up four or five times a night,
treat it for seven years,
and then 15 minutes later I grabbed a snake around her.
So that became my modus operandi results and that's where I came up with the
idea of coaching.
I said,
I'm not a motivator.
No one was using the term.
It's built kind of the beginning of an industry that my idea of coaching was not
going to get a certificate is you're paid for results.
So I would go and say,
you pay me nothing.
I'll do one session.
Give me the most impossible task on a turnaround.
You're addicted to a drug,
you're smoking the cigarette,
you're in this place.
And I built it.
I went to the United States army and they said,
give me a program,
we'll take any training program you have.
I'll cut the training time in half and increase the competency.
You pay me nothing.
He said,
you're crazy.
I said,
no,
I'm expensive.
And negotiated and I took a four day pistol shooting program and turn it a one
day program quantified a 100% of the people when before they'd only done 70% the
colonel wrote,
the general says the first breakthrough since World War One and pistol shooting,
I never shot a gun before it was this driving force.
Then I started with athletes.
Then all of a sudden I'm working with Princess Diana,
then President Clinton,
who by the way,
you're absolutely right cause he didn't,
it didn't have an AOL account back there.
I remember when I first started working there,
I said,
there's this new stuff called email.
I got this thing called all,
they will talk electronically.
He goes,
I've heard about that.
He didn't have an account in those days.
So and just brewed to businesses and individuals.
So every time you do something and you think you've done your best,
if you're a growing him and being,
you find out it's not your best.
There's a new level and you'll get there.
There's the new horizon.
If there is a passion to serve something bigger than yourself.
And if you're not limited,
just your thinking.
I believe the steep people get in signifies what capacity of their brain they're
going to be able to utilize and become an expert in changing your state.
Changing the story that limits that state.
And then finding the real strategy is the word.
Because I don't give a shit what state you're in.
If you're running east looking for a sunset,
you're screwed.
You've got to have the right strategy as well.
Those three things are,
I think we're going to do it for anybody.
Change Your strategy,
change your story,
change your state,
and you can pretty much change.
And it's,
and Tony d,
what was the last name of the NLP teacher that you mentioned?
Render John Grender,
one of the cofounders.
Got It.
And uh,
I think the commonality at least,
or one of the commonalities if I'm trying to piece together the patterns,
uh,
speaking to the two of you is that you put your reputation's where your mouth
was,
right?
In both cases,
uh,
in slightly different approaches.
But,
uh,
I just gets me so amped up.
My hands are getting sweaty.
Just thinking about big stuff.
Just listening to you guys.
Speaking of big things,
I want to make sure that we have ample time to cover something that we're,
we're all very excited about.
And that is the,
the global learning x prize.
And perhaps Peter,
you could chat about this before we jump into it though.
I want to mention a couple things to people.
Number One,
first and foremost,
very similar to Tony in this,
in this respect.
I've,
I've been a lifelong reader and autodidact.
I've had many incredible teachers,
but,
uh,
I've,
my most important teachers in many cases have come from books.
They've come a indirectly through words on a page.
And I was actually going to be held back my,
uh,
for kindergarten because I didn't learn to read.
And my teacher was convinced I couldn't read,
which was not the case.
What,
what,
uh,
what ended up being the problem is that she never explained why I should learn
the alphabet.
And then I got into first grade,
and this is Vince Gill.
I still remember her sit,
Tim,
I know you don't want to learn the alphabet,
but if you learn the alphabet you will be able to read books.
I was like,
well,
why didn't somebody tell me this and learn to read?
And that is the,
and so Mrs Minsky to this day,
uh,
you know,
I ended up being the Valedictorian of my,
uh,
my grade school because of her and she had competition.
So to just to bring it kind of full circle,
she had these little paper race cars that we would make and put them on a wall.
And there was a track with the number of books read and there was a competition
to get to the end.
And,
uh,
and I,
I got to the end like maybe a third of the way through the year and then we had
to sort of extend the,
the race track.
But it was all due to that passion she had for,
for reading and her ability to explain the benefits of it.
So as a Segue,
Peter,
maybe you could tell us a bit about the,
the global learning x prize,
which I'm
so excited about.
And thank you.
Thank you Tim.
So when I think about what are the world's biggest problems,
the problems that if we as society could fix,
would really transform this planet.
I mean that every mother and father and every person watching should really care
about,
there's one that when you pull that thread,
topples others.
And that's creating a world of literacy.
There's a billion illiterate people on the planet.
Two thirds of them are women and 250 million of them are kids.
And they live in the parts of the world that will never build enough schools or
teaching of teachers.
And I'll tell you one thing,
a population of people who are literate are more peaceful,
more prosperous and less populous.
In fact,
it was Bill Gates has a great ted talk and when she talks about the fact that
the,
you know,
there's something you can do to stop population growth rates and it's makeup
population healthier and more literate and you do that,
they,
you know,
growth stops.
In fact,
growth goes negative.
And it really is a key part of our world.
So a at x prize we every year have pulled together the smartest people in
applying and say,
where should we be focusing our next x prize?
We call this thing visioneering.
Tony's been a part of it.
Tim,
I would welcome your participation in the future.
And we add this debate and discussion with those smartest and wealthiest people
on the planet.
And literacy learning became the focal point.
So we set out to create something we call the global learning x prize.
And here's the question,
can we,
can we get entrepreneurs around the planet to build a piece of software that can
operate on any,
any fablet,
any tablet,
and take a child where there is nothing,
no literate adults,
no schools,
nothing.
And on their own,
take them to basic reading,
writing,
and numeracy.
And that's our,
and we fundamentally believe it is possible.
Got Amazing support from Nicholas Negroponte create one laptop per child who he
and Matt Keller who's running this prize for us actually did an experiment.
They took tablets,
uh,
into Ethiopia,
into villages that were a hundred miles from any schools,
uh,
any anything.
And they dropped the tablets off in a box and the kids opened the box,
learned on their own how to turn on the tablet,
how to use the apps and how to start learning to sound out words.
The problem they had was that the software was so poor,
it limited them.
And so our question is,
can we create what Neil Stevenson,
a great author and science fiction would call the young ladies illustrator
primer from,
from diamond age.
Can we create software that allows kids to teach themselves?
That's our challenge.
That's what the global learning x prize and about.
And,
uh,
I think there,
there are a couple of really important aspects to this that I'd love to
underscore for people.
Uh,
well first I'll just,
I'll second the,
the Neal Stephenson recommendation
and if you're going to start with one eye,
I'm a huge fan of snow crash cryptonomic on.
But coming back to the,
uh,
your boldest mission yet,
I think is what you called in an email that I received.
And,
uh,
there,
there are two things I think that the,
the,
I think it's worth talking about the old way,
uh,
and the challenges of trying to meet the demands of say,
250 million illiterate children.
How many,
at least based on what I've read,
it looks like that would take 1.6 million new teachers by 2015.
Needless to say,
doesn't seem like there's any way that the,
the old way with scale.
Right.
And,
uh,
another thing I want to sort of point out to folks is that if,
if you create a literate,
numerate mother,
uh,
or,
particularly younger women children,
uh,
you,
you tend to,
in many countries,
create educated families.
So there's,
there's sort of a false multiplier effect,
uh,
by,
by attacking this.
And the other thing I'd love you to talk about is,
uh,
maybe,
maybe you could just,
uh,
obviously comment on how people can get involved,
but the,
the,
the fact that it's not just using software to make people literate,
but there's a time constraint.
Yeah.
So I think it's 18 months,
is that right?
Yeah,
it was a friend,
a Elon Musk that challenged us to do it faster.
Um,
and then we originally planned it's 18 months.
So literally,
so the way this prize is going to work,
we announced it at the United Nations General Assembly.
Uh,
if I can say Tony,
uh,
Tony is one of our major benefactors underwriting the purse.
Uh,
we raised a $15 million of prize money for this and we announced it the UN a Ga,
we at the social good summit and at the Clinton Global Initiative by the honor
of closing out Cgi with President Clinton talking about this.
And we expect there will be hundreds if not thousands of teams competing for
this team can come from anywhere.
It can be a high school team,
it can be a team out of Microsoft.
The team out of Mumbai,
it doesn't matter.
And you've got to build a piece of software.
We're going to narrow it down from a thousand plus teams down to a top five and
those five we're going to deliver their software to us,
uh,
and they're each going to win $1 million of capital right there.
And that software has got to engage the student because if they,
if it's not exciting for them to use the software,
they're going to give up and put the tablet down and it's done game over.
It's got to actually be,
you know,
compelling enough and exciting enough and understand that child's favorite
movie,
Star Sports,
dark colored.
So it engages them in,
personalizes it in a way that makes them want to learn and we're going to
deliver that software.
Those five finalists are going to be delivered to 5,000 kids in sub Saharan
Africa and on 5,000 tablets and in a measure over 18 months where they go from
zero to how far they can go in terms of reading,
writing,
and numeracy.
And we're going to crown a winner.
It has to meet a certain level.
I won't go into detail now,
but the cool thing about this prize and like any other x prize,
the winning technology wins or the winning software winds 10 million bucks,
that's great.
But we also get the right to open source that software.
So imagine if the best software in the planet for teaching a child reading,
writing,
and numeracy.
Now it became available for free on every tablet and every smartphone put out
there,
there'll be a billion handsets in Africa by 2016.
I mean,
imagine if every one of them became the type of of compelling teaching
capability that a billionaire used or teenager.
Mumbai used the same,
the same way that Google is the same for Eric Schmidt,
for the poorest kid on the planet.
It's extremely exciting.
And,
uh,
obviously I want to direct people to a few places where they can learn more.
But I'd be curious,
Tony,
to hear from you.
You,
there's so many places you could invest your time and resources.
I'm sure you get asked to contribute to many,
many,
many different things.
Why is this,
why is this important to you?
Why have you decided to take such a sort of a large position in supporting it?
Well,
you know,
I look at the how do you create the greatest impact on the quality of people's
lives?
And if you listened to the three of us in this conversation as a sampling,
uh,
I believe that the thing that affects that most as learning,
I mean,
we are growing learning machines.
A person's ability to learn,
to grow,
to solve problems,
to be able to expand is what develops the quality of life for any human being.
That's what we're made for.
And it all starts in the world we live today in order to access the resources
and reading,
writing and arithmetic,
right,
numeracy,
those three components,
as basic as the art,
as boring of the sound to us,
they opened the door for all three of us.
I mean,
your story,
Tim,
about,
you know,
not wanting to run the alphabet,
but okay,
but then I could read because you understood it at some level even than that
reading would open another universe as it did to me.
I transported myself into other people's lives.
I transported myself and to new opportunities and new concepts,
new solutions.
All three of us had done this all through hasn't got this benefit.
Elon Musk has done that and I believe that self learning,
self directed learning is the most important of all because what's going to
happen in that environment is people's individual passions.
They're going to let them hack their own lives.
They're going to let them re vamp,
especially in the world we have today where,
let me think about it.
10 years ago we had what,
500 million people on the web?
It's hard to even imagine.
We've got 2 billion today and in six years we're going to have by billion 3
billion people are going to be joining that system,
but be able to take advantage of that system fully.
You've got to be able to have these fundamental skills.
So my whole thing has become a learning machine.
We sure as hell can't do that when you have such a large population of our
society and of our world,
that doesn't even have the opportunity to start with.
So we all know that children's inventiveness is extraordinary.
What we're really doing here is using tools and technology to literally open up
the worlds no matter where you live.
You know we're all lucky.
I mean,
but you look at how our lives have changed.
I'll give you another thing that I believe a principal and that's proximity.
We change proximity.
When Peter came up with this dream of his,
he put himself in proximity without different type of person over and over and
over again and shared his passion and story and that proximity opened up
opportunities.
You know,
books are a way of getting proximity when I didn't have physical proximity to
some of those solutions,
but that proximity for someone and South Africa,
somebody in certain parts of India,
some parts and parts of the third world to have there be no separation from your
capacity.
You have the same education that somebody has it mid that somebody has at
Stanford.
That stuff was coming online,
but it's worthless if you don't have the basic code.
That alphabet you talked about in the very beginning.
So I put my time,
my energy,
and my money on the line in this area because I don't think there's more
important we can give back to society helping other reason.
When you look at society and you see the problems that we have,
a lot of people think of these problems as somebody else's problems.
These are our problems.
Cause if you look at the biggest challenges in the world,
they come from the people in society that are forgotten.
They come from people that becomes so frustrated.
They don't have a way to come up with an empowering meaning.
They don't have a way to transport themselves,
they don't have a way to change the quality of their life.
And those are the individuals that turned to violence.
You know,
you think about it,
somebody asked me a few years ago,
I was in India and I literally left the hotel there in India,
I think about two days before the big bombing.
And I literally saw the bombing and two days after I'd been there and I was
talking with a friend and they were with a group of people.
One of the person's just saying,
how is this possible?
How does this type of violence possible?
How could somebody killed men,
women and children in this way?
And I said,
you know,
it's really possible because I'll tell you what's not possible for it wasn't a
happy person,
it wasn't a growing person,
it wasn't a fulfilled human being.
Happy person is not trying to destroy somebody else's life.
And if you want to know what makes human beings happy,
isn't money,
money,
we'll give you a certain level of happiness.
Depends on which study you read.
It is one thing,
one thing only progress.
Progress equals happiness.
If you feel like you're growing,
expanding,
and your psychology and your humanity and your emotion and your capacity and
your economics,
you feel alive.
We grow or we die.
And you put a giant limitation on that based on where you live in a world where
you're born,
unless you have access to certain resources and the most fundamental resources
learning.
But with technology now it doesn't matter where you live.
If you know how to learn the world is yours.
And so on a zero to 10,
to me this is a 1 million of importance and that's why I've committed the time,
energy and capital to help make it work.
And it's why all the other people are doing the same that are part of this team.
Absolutely.
Well said.
And I want to point out something else.
I'll send it to those techies listening cause I know a lot of,
lot of techies out there listening to this.
Uh,
and even those who are not necessarily technically trained,
I am not uh,
would find the fact that open source,
there's an aspect of open source that we didn't really touch on and is not only
is it freely available to people to use in some way and some,
uh,
interpretation in some like user interface but people can,
it is then available to be improved upon.
So I think it's very fascinating that,
let's just say hypothetically we have these teams,
five teams are given a million each.
They,
they,
they bust their asses.
Think big,
create really innovative software to try to solve this problem.
Finally you find,
you find the winner.
The code is made available,
uh,
people are becoming literate,
who can then improve upon the software itself.
It's just a very sort of a virtuous,
recursive aspect of the whole thing that is really,
really cool.
And a,
so guys,
everyone listening,
those of you who followed me for a while know that I don't get this excited
about a lot of things,
but I've been waiting to pick this shot for a long time.
Uh,
and I've talked about my passion for education,
uh,
and,
and reforming education,
improving education,
which is really improving learning since my,
my ted talk in 2008.
And,
uh,
there've been very few opportunities to really use an Archimedes lever to,
to sort of move the world.
And I think this is,
this is very legitimately one of them.
So,
uh,
Peter,
maybe you could,
um,
well there,
there are two things.
The first is,
uh,
as we know,
based on the results of the spectacular results of the x prize,
that people respond to incentives and,
um,
that's not,
uh,
being good or bad as being human.
People respond to incentives.
So we have obviously for those people who are interested in trying to develop
this software and compete for the prize,
uh,
where should they,
where should they go?
Where can they learn more?
Yeah.
If you go to [inaudible] dot org our website,
you can click on the learning x prize there and there's information about how to
register as a team,
how to preregister right now.
And it's pretty easy.
Just tell us you're interested in forming a team and get involved.
Um,
we'll take it through the process.
You know,
if you're a commercial company,
great.
If you're a,
a nonprofit or a startup,
whatever.
I know that when we give people a very clear target,
uh,
it drives them,
it focuses them and uh,
it's a great thing whether you enter the competition in the final result or not.
So [inaudible] dot org is how you can register.
Excellent.
And,
um,
I just just mentioned to people,
you know,
I had a conversation with a good friend of mine recently who's made hundreds of
millions of dollars and he's a very grounded,
deep,
soulful guy.
And we went for a hike because I've,
I've been trying to decide on sort of my next chapters,
so to speak,
the next projects that I pick.
And the way he encouraged me to think about it,
he,
he gave me a couple of questions to ask myself and one of them was,
you know,
if your goal were to be remembered in the history books,
metaphorically two,
300 years from now,
what could you do?
And he sort of engineer it in reverse that question.
You know,
if your goal is to have a big impact,
let's get very specific.
If you're going to be remembered two,
300 years from now or more,
what could you do?
And I would actually pose that to people listening to this.
And I would say one of the answers is winning this competition.
Uh,
I really feel like it could,
uh,
have that great an impact.
Uh,
I mean,
you could really go down in history for this one.
So that's point number one.
Point number two,
for those people who just want to perhaps look at some very,
very fascinating prizes.
If you'd like to support the global learning x prize,
there's an Indiegogo page so you can go to indiegogo.com and just search x
prize,
no hyphen needed.
And the first thing that will pop up,
and I'll also include this link in the show notes for people in the global
learning x prize.
But,
uh,
there were a couple of prizes there,
there prizes for every price point all the way from $25 or $10 even up.
But,
uh,
Peter,
maybe you could comment on,
I thought you could,
maybe you could elaborate on one of them,
which is the,
uh,
the 10th anniversary and sorry,
x xpress ticket.
Well,
actually,
if I,
if I could,
let me get a context of why this is important because it's really critical for
people to realize.
We do have amazing people like Tony Robbins,
who I love dearly,
who was put up $1 million here.
We raised the capital and you can say,
why would my $10 or $25 even make a difference here and why should I support
this?
And let me tell you why.
As an organization,
we have been dependent on a lot of extraordinary philanthropists.
I want to change that.
I really want the x prize to become an organization where the public decides
what the biggest problems in the world that need to be solved are,
and then vote on those and capitalize those prizes and literally create the
future.
It's like,
we want to solve this problem.
Great.
We'll crowdsource the rules.
We will ways the capitol,
and we'll solve that promise.
Literally creating the future.
It's,
it's throwing yourself a touchdown pass.
And this Indiegogo campaign is a,
is a means for me to prove to the x prize board into the world that the crowd
wants to be involved in helping to capitalize these prizes and cares about this
model for solving grand challenges.
So it's not about to half a million dollars in the million dollars will make,
you know,
donate 10 bucks.
I'm happy with that,
but get involved because we want to open this up so that it's really the world
solving its own problems,
stopping complaining about problems with starting,
solving problems.
That mindset is so critically important for society today.
Um,
the,
the second thing is where are we going to use this money that we raise?
So we today are basically taking these,
uh,
the software,
these tablets out to 5,000 kids in sub Saharan Africa.
Our goal is to double that number and in success we'll go to 10,000 kids,
not in a hundred villages,
but 200 villages to really statistically get the numbers working best and to
really see the major impact of this global learning x prize can have.
Um,
and so how can you be involved?
Uh,
lots of ways.
you know,
like you said,
Tim,
it's from 10 bucks up to 10,000 bucks.
Two of my favorite,
uh,
if I could is,
is one of them is for Ford for 25 bucks.
You can get actually access to the winning software for your kid or your niece
or your friend 18 months before it goes open source.
So we're going to be a actually taking the five finalists and making that,
those finalists available to,
uh,
backers of this.
So if you want to play with the software yourself,
25 bucks means you care about this prize and we'll give you a download code when
the software as going out to kids in Africa,
you'll get a chance to download it too.
And they don't have to be technical in order to use it.
No,
it can be.
It's going to be an android app you download and use pretty instantly.
You'll,
in fact,
you have to be as technical as the,
as the eight year olds in Africa that we're,
uh,
that we're,
that we're working with.
And then another very cool one,
if I could,
uh,
is at at 50 bucks,
you get to be involved in visioneering.
Visioneering is this thing that we do.
140 people,
Ceos,
top philanthropists.
You can become a digital vision year.
You get to vote on which x prize we should focus on next year.
So you get to help direct where the x prize,
what grand challenge on the planet we're working towards.
Next.
You care about climate,
do you care about water health?
What is it?
Uh,
you get involved.
So this is about really inclusion.
Uh,
and that's really why I want people involved here.
Show you care,
get involved,
help us really change the world on a massive scale.
Definitely.
And,
uh,
you know,
for the,
for those of you who will,
who are interested in,
uh,
in really doubling down in other ways,
you can also,
uh,
you have a chance to spend some time with,
with,
with Peter Himself,
Sir Richard Branson and others,
the 10th anniversary Ansari x prize,
a event.
And then also,
uh,
maybe Tony could talk a little bit a bout a date with destiny.
So this is a,
an opportunity to spend some time with Tony himself.
Uh,
and uh,
that is also an option on the,
on the Indiegogo page.
But,
uh,
perhaps Tony,
you could mention just a little bit about that.
I didn't even know was there
any way I can say,
well,
you know,
there,
there we go
once a year.
That's six day process.
It's my most intensive program and uh,
you know,
people from sports,
entertainment,
business,
average people.
We have people usually from usually about 40 to 50 countries.
We translate six or seven languages.
And the outcome of those six days is most of us don't understand that there is,
uh,
you know,
a software program,
if you will,
an operating system that really controls how you think and experience every part
of your life.
We know that generally we know what we value and what we believe generally,
but we take that down to a level that's my mind boggling where you will
understand why you think the thought you think,
feel the feelings you have.
And more importantly,
once you understand what's really the controlling force in your entire life,
you rewire it because you can't change something you're unaware of.
And then you just have a random life.
And I don't care.
Some people have had randomness that's brought a lot of greatness to their life.
So you find what's great in your life and if I met what's not and you find out
the real source and cause of it,
and it's an experience that is,
I mean you laugh more,
you cry more,
your entertainment level because it's raw and real and you see changes that are
unbelievable.
You'll see a,
you know,
a guy that's just come back.
You know the last thing we did from Afghanistan who shell shock,
who you know as PTSD can't sleep at night.
He's got the shivers when he tries to hold the microphone as your hand is
shaking out of control and he just stands up.
You never know who's going to stand up and you know,
you see him 45 minutes later and he's not shaking,
you know,
longer literally take his glasses off.
There's a physiological change in him where he can have light sensitivity.
I brought him on CNN.
To give you an example,
just show people what's possible.
You'll see a,
a young woman who's faced,
has been disfigured and thinks her life is horrific and literally there is a
transformation her,
she saw her about six months ago and she's got a relationship for the first time
I life.
You see a person that has made more money than God,
who's achieved more than they ever have it in there,
bored out of their mind and frustrated with their life.
And you find out that guess what,
you know that solution is not the solution.
And then you see what they're transformed like afterwards and you participate in
these processes.
So was just the most intensive individual program that I do.
And instead of doing it with five or 10,000 people,
it's the most intimate thing I do when you'd do it with about 1800 2000 people
and you get to develop family of people in France and all over the world.
So it's the ultimate,
if you want to transform,
you want to learn what controls and shapes your life,
the ultimate of that experience.
And if you make some donation,
I don't know what it is you're in.
Let me just tell you,
you donated 10 seats at the 10 k level and actually being matched with another
10 case.
If you donate a 10,000,
you get to come to day with destiny.
And Tony,
you've said you'll,
you'll take a photo and spend a few moments with those individuals,
which are your time is the most precious thing.
And I can say that having done date with destiny myself,
with you,
I learned more in six days and I learned in four years in Mit.
It's the most extraordinary experience in my life.
I love you too,
pal.
So,
uh,
guys,
I know you,
uh,
you have,
worlds to conquer out there and uh,
the global learning x prize is,
is really something that has reinvigorated me and in a way that has kind of been
a longtime coming for me,
I feel.
And I,
I really feel like for those of you listening who are in any way passionate
about education and you've been wondering how to pick your shot,
how to throw that,
that one touchdown pass,
I really feel like this is an excellent place and it's very time sensitive to
focus your energy and uh,
I'm going to be obviously getting behind it as I am and,
uh,
doing some things to,
to help move the needle.
And uh,
you can go to [inaudible] dot org if you want to compete plenty of money on the
line and a glory lasts forever,
right?
So,
so that's one.
And then if you want to check out the Indiegogo campaign,
I will put the link in the show notes so you can just go to the blog for our
blog.com and click on podcast and can find the show notes.
Or you can just go to indiegogo.com and search for x price without a hyphen.
Before we take off.
Do you gentlemen have any,
any parting comments,
advice,
recommendations,
uh,
restaurant,
restaurant tips,
anything at all that you don't have to leave with us before we go?
Something?
Could you see the combination of all three of us and I see it,
I think you'll see it in anybody that's enjoying their life.
You know,
it's,
the game never ends for the game of mastery.
It's about finding a way to do something and do it so well that goes beyond
yourself.
That if you can find your passion,
you can find anything you're passionate about and you don't know what it is.
I think gets getting around people that are really passionate.
It's getting around where it's better and letting something hit you.
You can't get around a person like yourself or like Peter and not be touched or
something inside of you.
It's going to get ignited.
So if you don't have that passion yet,
they're listening,
you know,
listening to these podcasts as a way to get some of that proximity.
But I'd go pursue putting myself in an environment where you're going to be
stimulated and if you know what your passion is,
and the question is,
how can you surround yourself with the best of the best that you can be
challenged?
Because the idea of on the x prize really is,
it's not just the incentives,
it's also the challenge.
It's that competition to say,
how can I do more in less time for more people than I've ever done in my life?
And when that becomes your focus,
something happens to the vibratory rate of the human brain and insights come,
you start seeing things and the reticular activating system of the brain starts
finding answers because you have that focus on something larger.
So if you don't have it,
find it.
And if you don't know how to find it,
get yourself in environments consistently where people are living it and
something will hit you.
Wow.
Absolutely.
And that's,
that's,
that's part of the reason that people ask me why I live in Silicon Valley.
If I could live anywhere.
And that's,
it's,
it's not the tech,
it's that it's being around the people who believe that they're going to first
in the world.
Absolutely.
Uh,
Peter,
uh,
yeah.
I mean,
uh,
it all begins with passion.
There is no better teacher mentor on the planet than Tony Robbins when it comes
down to that for me.
I'll just add on top of that,
that there is no problem we cannot take on,
you know,
the world's biggest problems are the world's biggest business opportunities.
I mean,
which is amazing to think about.
You know,
you want to become a billionaire,
help a billion people.
That convergence and the notion that a single individual to the,
I don't care who you are in the world where you are in the world,
you have access to extraordinary capabilities.
You have access to,
you know,
the world's knowledge and information on Google.
You have access to Ai,
to cloud printing,
all these exponential technologies and at the same time you've got access to all
the expertise you want through crowdsourcing.
You have capital through crowdfunding.
So my goal here is to say,
first and foremost,
connect with your passion that drive that with you,
and then take your moonshot.
Where are you going to take and do something significant that gives meaning.
I love that example you,
you give Tim about how you'll be remembered,
you know,
two,
300 years from today.
Uh,
so it's an amazing time to be alive.
It's an amazing time to be an entrepreneur.
I am thankful to him for who you are in the world and Tony and uh,
and blessed to be honest conversation with you guys.
Gentlemen,
thank you so much for taking the time.
Uh,
I would,
wouldn't be really fun to get together in person at some point.
I know we're on different coasts and constantly flying,
but,
uh,
the,
this virtual proximity will do for now and uh,
everybody check out the x prize.
It is a,
it is very worthwhile and there are plenty of incentives for every player in the
game.
And,
uh,
if you're looking for that passion that,
that Peter mentioned,
and you don't know what that passion is.
As Tony mentioned,
one of the best ways to get passionate is to be surrounded by people who are
very passionate and thinking magnitudes of order above the average Joe or Jane
you may be surrounded by.
And a great way to do that honestly is just a checkout,
even the page that describes this x prize on x prize.org or on Indiegogo.
And uh,
you might just find that as is the case with me.
Uh,
it's,
it's just,
uh,
it's PR,
it's provided some,
some intellectual gasoline and some passion,
uh,
that,
that you might not have seen in awhile.
So I think that it's worth checking out and I'll be doing a lot more related to
it.
So guys,
for the time being,
thanks so much for being on.
Thanks Peter.
Bye Bye.
Thank you for supporting the sponsors of this show.
I've used them,
I like them and I think you will too.
99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
it's the world's largest marketplace of graphic designers.
You can see the projects that I've put up,
the competitions that I've spearheaded,
including the book cover of the four hour body,
and you can also get a $99 upgrade for free,
so check it out@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim of course you can
subscribe to this show on iTunes.
You can also find every other episode in the show notes,
links from this episode@forourblog.com that's u r h o U R B l o g.com and just
click on podcasts.
There's all sorts of other cool stuff including my interactions with people like
Warren Buffet.
Much note of Lincoln Park.
The list goes on and on and on and I would love your feedback.
Let me know what you thought of this show.
Who would like to hear on the show next and any other thoughts really,
you can find me at Twitter at at t Ferris,
that's twitter.com forward slash t f e R I s s and on facebook@facebook.com
forward slash Tim Ferriss with two r's and two s's.
Until next time.
Thank you for listening.